what's up guys before we begin today's
video i just want to say a big thanks to
squarespace for sponsoring our video
today and for supporting
our channel we'll be talking more about
squarespace at the end of this video so
make sure to stick around
[Music]
good morning well actually right now
it's like afternoon now
but yeah it's been a long car ride yeah
we've been on the car for a long time so
we drove
from denver all the way to
manito cliff dwellings
so we just got here and apparently this
is
a preservation site it's really cool
like reconstructed
homes that are up against like inside of
rocks like i said it's a very limited
kind of vacation because of the fact
that we're in the middle of a pandemic
and so we're just trying to make do with
what we
can but here we are manito cliff
dwelling isn't that cool this is pretty
cool
[Music]
everything's red like the red rock stuff
huh looks like mars
looks like we're in uh an earth version
of mars this is our future
when we all leave earth we're gonna live
on mars this is what our life in
our mars is gonna look like i like the
music too
[Music]
it's pretty cool what do we gotta go
inside these
that was pretty awesome from what i
heard is that these aren't the original
kind of cliff dwellings i think those
are in in arizona or something but these
are like replicated and it's been open
since like 1904
here so they replicate like fires or
anything inside
fire freaking cold yeah oh yeah there's
a teepee over there yeah
look at the mountains over there yeah
that looks cool cool
there's like carvings and this is
sideways only let me see if i fit
almost remember in tulum they have like
really short doorways
that's true this is probably like
[Music]
yeah you want to light up the fire
yeah it's so cold
[Music]
nice and warm i know rotisserie
uh chicken on over this thing
yes please it's a great view of the
mountains
that's a weird oh yeah there we go kiva
turkey santa ate too much turkey what
have you
what of you
where's casey oh my gosh you went down
oh you already left
i was talking to you
so what do you think you want to take
the place moving in take it
we gotta get away from some bad guys
[Music]
we're in like a little room right we
have our little private quarters
[Music]
we got high ceilings very good real
estate here
very good we all always want high
ceilings got good lighting coming in
through the north wall over here i
wonder if it
would lay down yeah high ceilings and
good lighting but no room to lay down
i feel like i've dreamt of something
like this before oh yeah
yeah this looks familiar
[Music]
garden of god
they should just made a pun out of it
and just call it a god then
garden garden a garden we're in utah now
just kidding it looks like utah though
that's like all
the country all the states look to be
arizona it could be new mexico
it could be any wyoming i don't know
[Music]
hey guys so now we're checking out the
rocky mountain national park
[Applause]
look at that
wow this is so pretty frozen in time
oh smush i want to throw one too
let's see
it's frozen yeah there's a frozen river
be please be careful i'm no one to see
my wife fall into ice
last words i don't think i'll fall
can you stand on it
don't you do it don't you do it
that's cold tip over it's really cold
and it's really really windy
my nose is frozen and you look like
santa claus
touching my breath yeah how about you
guys
you guys good cold it feels like
minnesota minnesota have you never been
there
and then you look like the guy from
fargo with your whole getup
very appropriate it's really hard for me
to speak my mouth is like
it's frozen we're driving around this
whole national park
most of it is closed but we're trying to
find little pockets here and there where
we can still explore
but yeah i mean trying to make the most
out of this trip
you know
[Music]
we are now at bear lake nature trail and
it is roughly
3250 feet above sea level no the
trolling i didn't know nothing about it
fun fact that we found out is that the
trees in
the the forest here end up blocking the
wind so it makes it less
cold i know bubba what were you saying i
don't think so
baba was saying that it was very naive
of me to think that the trees would help
with the wind
why
of course i'm not saying it's completely
blocking it i'm just saying it helps
in reducing the wind no you don't feel
that
but you know one thing i hate about the
bathroom you see this rod right here
yeah how long does it take people to go
around it
it doesn't they don't tell you uh-huh
that's true
they don't tell you oh elevation
you know the best thing about you is
that no matter how covered
[Music]
yeah the whole wind was picking up the
snow and it looked like a little mini
snow storm we did so we're walking out
of the frozen lake
frozen lake around the lake
you're not scared we're walking we just
start hearing crack crack cracks
i don't think so it looks really sturdy
and plus i'm only following where other
people have stepped
all right so it's really really cold
yeah i don't know what else to say
standing on this frozen lake now
that's right that's what else we're on a
frozen lake so cool they can't even
think straight i know it's so
freaking cold my fingers are frozen i
just have to stick them in my mouth
right now just to pull them down
or warm them down i mean every once in a
while the augusta one will blow by
pick up a whole bunch of snow and just
smack you in the face yeah
i highly recommend but it's really
pretty it's really really pretty
yes very romantic man it's really cool
though that we're
actually on a lake like i've never
stepped foot on a frozen lake like this
i think
[Music]
you know me i'm a foodie i like eating
all weird all sorts of weird things and
colorado is known for having game meets
uh like i guess just at restaurants here
and there's like a
really popular buffalo bison burger
around somewhere didn't go there
just found a mom and pop burger spot
that elk meat here so
i hear elf meat's very sweet so i'm
going to test it out see what it's like
and see if it's better than a beef
burger looks like any old burger
it's like a good old-fashioned like
messy burger oh you want messy
this is messy man that's messy knife and
fork
only yeah i got a chili cheeseburger
and it's like really difficult to eat in
the car with
it tastes just like beef really oh
it does taste just like beef that
doesn't taste any different i guess i
know what you mean by it tasting sweeter
though
there is like a hint of gaminess in
there
but not enough to be like oh it's super
different you let me know tiff
it does taste a little different there's
an aftertaste there's definitely like a
little bit of an aftertaste
i like it though it makes it interesting
i came to denver
wanted to try some interesting game
meets and a lot of restaurants were
closed so
i thought that opportunity was out we
had left
the stage went out the i went out the
window
that [ __ ] that sailed thankfully we came
across this random spot hmm
very good all right so i just took a
bite of my brother's buffalo
buffalo yeah buffalo burger
way more gamier you let me know jeff i
could smell it already
um i think i got more lettuce and bread
than meat but
i'm trying to find it yeah i don't know
yeah i'm not understanding what
gamey means is it a flavor i think i got
too much of other stuff to taste it
and then plus this is like really
intense so i think it's like that looks
so good
the definition is the strong flavor or
smell of
game what does that mean can help you oh
like when
you go hunting so it smells like i don't
i just don't get it it makes no sense
all right guys now we're gonna be taking
a tour of the stanley hotel
here in i forgot the name of the city
but it's a melron
no no it's a city no it's like estes or
something
yeah yeah so it's a it's like this
mountain town
and this hotel is famous because it
inspired
stephen king's the shining we're also
gonna be taking a tour
and see if it really is haunted or not
just a bit clear this is not the filming
location yeah they didn't film it here
they're shining
they didn't film it here for sure i was
really excited for that whenever there
was inspiration for the hotel
racing i was like oh also cool just this
is cool
very very different yeah so stephen king
and his wife stayed here for one night
and that one night that they stayed here
they were like the only guest in the
entire hotel because the hotel was
closing for the winter season or
something i guess dear king
talked about how he would like roam the
empty hallways and it was just so eerie
and then like his bathtub in his room he
ended up thinking like oh i wonder if
anyone's died here or something like
that i don't know carrie was telling us
the shining inspiration stuff that
stephen king has
has talked about but fun fact the
bartender that served stephen king his
strength his name was grady which
actually is the name of the character
of the carpenter so that made it into
the movie that's cool
i didn't hear that part of the story but
the view though
this view i don't know if the camera can
really pick it
right here yeah this view right here
right here
it's just amazing i know your chin is so
huge
[Music]
yeah that ends up like pushing your your
mask down
with this chin i also need like a bigger
nose to kind of like
oh yeah to lock in here like look in the
mask on both ends
that's funny i have no nose no one knows
your nose
no one knows i have a nose and
something about chin chinny chin yeah
[Music]
all right just like in the shining at
the end of the movie
when he's chasing her through the maze
trying to kill her the family has a maze
too
look the hedge maze give me an axe i'll
chase you around the maze
uh can we just do it without the ex
i'll chase you
he's like he's like
do you want to see if we can oh no
unless this place is haunted like it is
and it makes you go a little
loopy
just kidding play hard
too much too much too much work makes
johnny out
what was it mix jacka no johnny wasn't
it johnny
i thought it was johnny mama you're
enjoying the maze yeah
[Music]
i was falling tiff around the maze like
a steadicam with my bare hands fun fact
they made the very
first steadicam of all time for the
movie shining
so credits to uh stan kubrick for making
city cams which are now
the modern day version of that is uh
gimbals
gimbals are a really popular thing that
you can buy for vlogging and whatnot for
everyone anyone that makes videos on
youtube right just walked in
pretty epic
[Music]
imagine being stuck here all by yourself
i know
i mean i want to see the hallways me too
that's sick
old school
[Music]
my dad just go straight for the fire
tables nice and warm over there that's
crazy
the frozen running waterfall
okay no more fun fact so while this
hotel served as the inspiration for the
shining
for stephen king's novel this was
actually the filming place for
the number so it wasn't absent
never never made it the shining the tv
series
was filmed here oh okay right yeah
this is what it says we actually have it
here for the movie it's all work and no
play make jack a double you're right
about jack
yeah i said johnny huh because when he
goes where
there's john in here
[Music]
this is where all the rich fancy people
would watch the concert
oh rich fancy people
that's not me dude you should have seen
what it looked like downstairs it looks
so scary
is there any ghosts that want to take a
selfie with me
i dare you to come out where did you see
that oh i was gonna say
[Music]
so we were told this room has a lot of
apparitions and images that pop up
mirrors through the song and through
photographs and stuff so now we're
trying to
capture something through photographs
from the phone
now we're just taking a whole bunch of
pictures of the mirrors to see if we can
get
mr mrs stanley yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
looking for twin girls looking for twin
and girls well i'll show you the hallway
that stephen king probably envisioned
those two
oh perfect
[Music]
all right so room 217 is a very infamous
room where
a an accident had happened many many
years ago and
jim carrey actually stayed here during
filming dumb and dumber he got freaked
out by that room
and requested to leave
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the darkest elevator ever it looks
paranormal in here
super space is going to pop up right in
the mirror
we survived whoa
creepy what's in there what's in there
who's the party in the dark
once again thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video if you guys
didn't know squarespace gives people a
powerful platform
from which to create a website for
example if you want to create a
photography website to showcase your
work
squarespace offers professional
portfolio designs that allow you to
customize the layout
so that you can make it your own then
when people want to hire you for
photography
make sure to add online booking and
scheduling to your website with
squarespace that takes the hassle out of
coordinating calendars with clients
squarespace also has powerful tools for
growing in an audience through
email create email content which matches
the feel of your website so
everything feels consistent and stays
effective go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch
go to squarespace.com tiffcase to save
10 after first purchase
of a website or domain i used to be
really into photography and
back in the day if i had this i would
totally use squarespace so make sure to
check them out
peace out
[Music]
mmm